Ryan
what an element
I am still not over it okay
I just talked to James I'm double
elimination again not over it so how are
you feeling today now that everything's
out there for you your family your
friends Survivor fans who have seen the
episodes
um my family didn't know when I got
voted off I did I didn't tell them
anything my girlfriend didn't have no
idea no idea I wanted them to experience
it and really be surprised really yeah
if you know what's the what's the fun so
last night when I lost that that that's
my brothers who are those muscles for
you should have beat me up stop you
don't understand I tripped in the
beginning and lost my balance and I did
I I was trying to move forward too much
and lost my balance oh my God I'm gonna
have to catch it and that was a lot
harder once it's here than it is when
it's here
um but I'm getting so much support from
fans that have reached out to me since I
saw the first episode I was honored to
be the first person after Jeff talking
about my life experience and what I've
been through it really meant a lot to me
and it meant a lot to a lot of other
people I had a mother reaching out and
she told me
um I was in the kitchen and my daughter
she has cerebral palsy as well and she
wants to survive and she goes mom the
first person that talked
to be able to be that for somebody
because I didn't have that um I'm the
first person I know that has cerebral
palsy that's done something like this on
Miles through because
I've been on TV and Bend myself to try
to uplift others because that's who I am
and it's really shown through because
there's so many responses saying thank
you for you know being yourself and
you've been such an inspiration to me
and my husband to have hope for our son
and our daughter or from people that
have cerebral palsy themselves and it's
nice because like I said growing up I
didn't have anybody like that and there
was a part of me that was honestly
rejected because I was different it got
me bullied it got me pushed around it it
made me fall behind but it just
getting past those obstacles pushed me
further and taught me how to be myself
to the point where I can encourage
others to do so even with a disability
or even with a speech impediment or or
something that makes you different do
you accept yourself and are honest with
yourself you can't be honest with others
and without that you can't have the
people that need to be around today
oh that's so sweet my heart oh that's so
nice and I wanted to tell you anyways
thank you for sharing your story I feel
like this season there have been so many
Amazing Stories and so many important
messages that I've
um never had the opportunity to get out
there on such a big platform so again
thank you for sharing your story and
that was so sweet and so touching I'm so
glad to hear that
um and I love that your family had no
idea what was happening so I love that
you kept it a secret okay my girlfriend
let's go back Tribal Council when you
walked in for your group and you saw
James sitting on the jury bench what was
going through your head
yes
I have nothing against James
um people thought we were close but we
also our perspectives were different the
way we do things were different so
there'd be times where we would butt
heads but immediately it was like we
were related oh it's like Oh you mean
like that okay okay you're gonna do it
like that and so we were in a way I was
trying to keep some type of currency
with the three other Coco and talking
with James he was like my Inside Man to
make it look like you know I was in the
house but at the same time I found that
I was on the bottom of that seven or at
least near the bottom of that seven that
saved me from the Dwight boat
so I need to find some type of like
somewhere else so I tend to work well
with people that aren't on the top or
are outcasts in real life not
necessarily Outcast but different and I
seek them out almost to bring out the
best in them because once you become
somebody like that friend they're
they're amazing they're fantastic so I
thought that same way in in Survivor I
went to the people on the outs like Noel
who lives up other than white ball or
Owen who's been left out almost every
vote
um Jesse who had told me his uh Cody who
would probably his number one was voted
out when he came to the beach and gabler
who was really destroying the slide some
type of Alliance and he had also came to
me and told me hey I voted for you I'm
sorry and that gained some type of
respect for me so I was trying to weave
my way into another Alliance to weaken
the other one to make it to like a final
five but it's a lot harder than it looks
I can only imagine I Can Only Imagine
so then on a scale of one to ten how
confident were you not thinking of what
was going to play out or did you have
any idea that your name was like up
there and that you would have the
potential to go home
so mentally consciously I would look at
an eight eight nine but in my gut
Something Told Me pray that shell
because if you don't bring that that can
shout you're not gonna have it and I did
it was Heavy it was definitely heavy in
that Survivor bag I even had to like
adjust the knot properly so I could like
hold it with my arm instead of just
having it on my shoulder to carry my
torch so something told me you might be
going home I wish I screamed a little
bit louder so at least played my shot in
the dark but um I'm gonna ask that you
know
I just I didn't think I'd seen it quite
so many times and I didn't think you
know if I vote
and play if I don't vote for my shot in
the dark the people that
vote with me or nothing trust me because
they didn't think I tested them so it
was more of a Do or Die situation and
with my luck I probably should have
played my shot in the dark I would have
probably been the first person in
Survivor history to actually be safe
I know well we haven't seen really
anything successful from shopping I feel
like we need that to happen so maybe it
will but I just to jump on that I kind
of lived for the whole moment about the
Clans and the carrying of the clams if
you're gonna go home
and because you know you're the provi
you're the provider of that tribe like
let's be honest here so I was loving
that so like where did the clams go did
they come with you to Ponderosa or like
what did you do with them
so first I want to say I didn't take the
life plan we ate the clam you know sorry
yeah yeah yeah it's because somebody
else asked me I had to make sure
somebody asked me if I took the live
plan I really know I didn't take the
lifetime no
sells I actually got taken back to
Ponderosa but once they got there they
told me hey I'm
you're free to try it but there's a
twenty thousand dollar sign for bringing
back Wildlife from Fiji to America and I
was like that's not worth it I I don't
want to do it you guys can keep it so
it's at Ponderosa right now and it's
like a little altar I made with other
shells around it I hope it's still there
oh you know what they really shouldn't
get rid of it so let's cross our fingers
but it's still there
um so after everything played out and
you were sent to the jury in that moment
was there someone who you're like oh my
gosh they're playing the best game right
now or even after watching it last night
were you like what a great game move
like who would you say is playing the
strongest Game In This Moment
um
Jesse
um nobody knew he had too many title
nobody knew you guys knew before we
actually
but he thought that thing was hot so the
fact that Jesse has Janine's Idol
um at the last moment because I didn't
know Jesse and Cody were saying
um at one point I went to Cody and I was
like he was talking to me about hey can
can we get Jesse in instead of Owen with
that group you're trying to make and I
was like I just don't have a
relationship with that uh with Jesse as
much and I went away and I came back and
I said you know what
if I was in your shoes and I asked that
I would want my thoughts to be heard or
my feelings to be heard about who I
wanted in it because you know what I I
tried to organize the rest of it so yeah
I you know if you trust yes yeah and
then I went home and I was like
they're working together all right so
what's up I'm so shocked I feel like at
least for a viewer it's so obvious that
they're working together but I guess
it's a little different
I guess it's the amount of time I spent
um I was comfortable like the wind wall
was so I could see from the beach
because I have I had had a back injury
uh from a car accident and caused
something where they're just going like
40. so I'm sitting on the plane the Fiji
was terrible so I couldn't sleep on the
bamboo so I slipped on the beach and the
wind was terrible so I made that wall
because there's not enough room up on
the in the jungle followed us asleep and
I made it and so many people came down
this is awesome
that's a win
win ball
um but it was it was
hard to see with what I was given who
was really aligned um I noticed Sammy
was you know sneaking through I thought
I could trust Gaber more but he could
make a strategic move for his game
getting me out of that point and going
with Jesse and and Cody that made sense
um but at the time everything's crazy
oh that's what it was but
um yeah when I by the time I got almost
okay that makes more sense now I I get
where they were going with it there you
go well I love that I just love I'm such
a Survivor fan so hearing all this back
stuff and all the stories is so
interesting to me all right and just to
wrap this up although your journey
didn't end obviously the way you hoped
it would
um would you say besides obviously not
winning would you say it was everything
else that you dreamed it would be
I went out there with this whole purpose
to 100 enjoy myself leave everything out
there that I wanted to do I didn't want
to come back and be like I just spent
two two and a half weeks arguing with
people and trying to get people to vote
at each other instead of enjoying my
time it's easy I went out there and I
enjoyed Fiji and I argued with people
about who the [ __ ] out so I had a
complete experience I got
In the Flesh that was amazing his eyes
are so blue right it's uh he's an
amazing guy wow yeah I definitely did
everything on my bucket list playing
surviving other than finding an immunity
aisle and winning in the visual immunity
those two things I still need to do
so maybe they need to invite you back
you need to go back on the show
definitely and this time I will
definitely not provide as much so people
are hungry and fighting so I can
strategize the chaos instead of just you
know making everybody happy and meet it
made it too easy for them there you go
well I would like to see it so let's uh
well thank you so much time I can't wait
to see you on the jury still we're still
going to see you on the show on the jury
so uh yeah thank you so much for your
time
thank you